oh [ __ ] it's your lucky morning [ __ ]
uncle Joey in full effect
what are you nuts so what uncle Joey
here the Lord's Day January 29th get
your [ __ ] together
the Holy Smoke is coming at you it's
been a good [ __ ] week
but next week it's gonna be better Joey
but he signed a bunch of executive
orders last what who gives a [ __ ] y'all
[ __ ] that kind of water didn't shoot
was to [ __ ] the only the only
executive water hidden sign was the one
that shot you in the [ __ ] head that
means you're alive that means you got
another week to sling dick and do this
on your own [ __ ] rules you understand
me but hey enough with the chitter
chatter I showed up all with the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit company
understand me I don't [ __ ] around it's
the Lord's that you can't show up but oh
I just smoked some weed I got a body how
about I kick in the [ __ ] liver that's
a body right you dumped [ __ ] body hi
look at that
well you think that'll give me that bone
give me no [ __ ] body hi body huh
that's a new thing these [ __ ]
Gentiles do some [ __ ] heroin you
[ __ ] Momo a body huh what is wrong
with you [ __ ] nothing poops anyway -
beautiful day to be alive the Lord's
[ __ ] shining on you the Sun is out
there it's ready to [ __ ] go I got you
jet till today I got to do a little
riding and I got the family that's it
and that's dead
I'm born in Nashville on [ __ ]
Thursday I'll see you [ __ ] at
Sammy's but listen enough is enough
let's get this party [ __ ] started
we're gonna open up with some [ __ ]
where is this perennial from perennial
well via one of my favorite [ __ ]
spots around here them buds and roses
and sunset herbal they don't [ __ ]
understand me those are my peeps they
know when I walk in there I'm looking to
see the [ __ ] devil am I look at my
teeth get the [ __ ] out he was wrong with
these people
that's all you need to [ __ ] know on
the Lord's neck you want to have a good
week
you got a spell with Sunday's gotta be
tip-top [ __ ] beautiful your Gold's
your push-ups what you want out of a
week and let me tell you something
before you know it it's right there your
life is right in front is the power of
the pen is a [ __ ] little
kissable [ __ ] about pens and feathers
and ain't give a [ __ ] I'm trying to
spark here I get this body started a
little protein shake I took a nice
little [ __ ] [ __ ] I wash my [ __ ]
with them and dad took a shower you know
I did what I [ __ ] had to do and that's
all you gotta wash your [ __ ] nuts a
crime the Lord's Day I went to church I
put a fin in the [ __ ] basket and
that's it I'm good for the [ __ ] week
jack
oh that that's a [ __ ] cloud of joy
right there if I've ever seen
let's fire this up without missing
something you guys know I smoke a lot of
weed I tell you is this [ __ ] to kill the
devil this is the [ __ ] that killed Gary
Fisher this is the [ __ ] to kill John
Hurt
this is the [ __ ] that just kills
everybody this presidential let me tell
her I got the first night I was craving
potato chips at dream [ __ ] up more I
don't even like [ __ ] potato chips I'm
scraping a nice bag of wise onion garlic
potato chips with a [ __ ] roast beef
I'm rise from mash ways salt and pepper
heavy on the Mayo and I'm saying maybe
some macaroni salad maybe a [ __ ] but
anyway that was then this is nothing
that's what happens when you smoke good
weed you crave this [ __ ] from you
[ __ ] eat you can't even I'm saying
some we just get your eyes he's not a
[ __ ] Big Mac it's right there but
when we makes you [ __ ] stone so make
you crave this [ __ ] you wait as a child
that's when you know that weed is good
it's diplom do you [ __ ] being a jack
see I'm not an untapped late after pro
ball you gotta wait another week to
watch [ __ ] the Super Bowl but I want
to congratulate [ __ ] shall link go to
chick with the [ __ ] armbar Juliana
pan yet I want to congratulate my
brother Jorge Maz vedalam a great
[ __ ] fight I want to congratulate
that little white dude from Mississippi
you know fighting his heart dawg
they get paid peanuts they get treated
like [ __ ] savages we don't even know
the other end of it you know time but
you gotta applaud them you gotta do
something all these [ __ ] riders
this [ __ ] that write about MMA they'd
never even done a [ __ ] jumping jack
in the face like this just walking
around and [ __ ] open that [ __ ] up a
modern good [ __ ] time I'm promoting
it you have the best week of your
[ __ ] life cuz you're broke your goals
down today and you focus you told those
[ __ ] what are we gonna do Trump who
gives a [ __ ] I gotta [ __ ] get my dick
sucked seven days a week does not know
whether they understand me and listen no
biggest ed takes up seven days a week
unless you're [ __ ] Richard Gere or
something like that what I'm saying is
that you're making strides or seven days
a [ __ ] week constantly I'm talking
anyway so the church tomorrow night 8
o'clock Wednesday 8 o'clock Nashville
Sammy's Thursday 8 o'clock and then the
[ __ ] rest for a week I'm Pat the
party starts Thursday if you're not that
Thursday don't [ __ ] come alright only
our professionals go on Thursday Stars
bazookas landmines whatever you [ __ ]
looking for in your life will be at
Zanies Thursday night and that's it
that's it unless then I know how do you
a my's [ __ ] but that's the purpose of
this whole thing that's the reason why
we have this little tape day on the
Lord's Day
should we do another one more for the
[ __ ] Road
now to get my Poquelin shoot you know me
I gotta fix this [ __ ] right now you're
smoking all weed on the bottom it's
choo-choo we did the Animal Planet show
everything worked out I'm very excited
about it but now we move on to the next
[ __ ] venue of our life where's that
Venu
I'm not [ __ ] I did I don't every
day's a little bunch every day's a
winding road you're right and that's it
and that's that
nothing better than getting together
with you people on the Lord's Day you
don't miss your last couple days but
videos when up listen I thought meant
you Sunday through Wednesday after
Thursday I leave you to [ __ ] along you
don't need me in your life that much I
don't need you in my life what goombazz
me I'm saying but I'm not here to
[ __ ] being your face constantly now
we take a break from time to time we
surprise you
and we smoke a little potato I say
together but that's it meds that I see
your [ __ ] tomorrow morning
tip-top Magoo with the [ __ ] god of
life ready to sling thick with the
Chinese and then tomorrow night 8
o'clock on the Churchill was happening
now